finnland war schon immer vorreiter bei
der chancengleichheit was machen die
finden besser frage ich mich auf den weg
nach helsinki
als erstes land der welt konnten hier
frauen wählen und gewählt werden
1907 war das jetzt schaut die welt
wieder nach finnland
[Musik]
fünf frauen ganz oben
ministerpräsidentin ministerinnen alle
parteichefinnen vier von ihnen mitte 30
ich treffe die andersen 34 jahre alt
bildungsministerin politik hat sie schon
als jugendliche gemacht seit 2016 bis
die chefin des linksbündnisses
lässig aber völlig uneitel so mein
eindruck morgens beim ersten termin im
ministerium
die haarsträhne die sich bei der
videobotschaft für eine
lehrlingswettbewerb aus ihrem zopf löst
egal das bleibt so
fast zwei jahre sind sie und ihre
kolleginnen an der regierung noch immer
sorgt das für aufmerksamkeit
viele ausländische sender kommen hier
und wollen über finnlands frauen an der
macht sprechen sind sie davon schon
gemerkt
nein bin ich nicht aber ich erinnere
mich als uns die fernseh crews anfangs
gefragt haben wie es für frauen ist
zusammenzuarbeiten und niemand hat uns
irgendetwas über unsere politik gefragt
der fokus war immer auf dem geschlecht
und viel weniger auf den leitlinien
unserer regierung
wie erklären sie sich dass finnland so
vorne liegt wie ist es möglich dass die
frauen an der spitze stehen
ja ich denke das hat ganz viel mit der
arbeit zu tun die sehr viele frauen vor
uns gemacht haben sowohl in der politik
als auch in anderen teilen der
zivilgesellschaft
sie haben die gläserne decke
durchbrochen das hat es einfacher
gemacht für frauen nach ihnen karriere
in der politik zu machen
in finnland liegt der frauenanteil im
parlament bei 47% im kabinett sind es
sogar 63 prozent mehr als in deutschland
2000 gab es die erste präsidentin und
2003 die erste premierministerin
kein wunder dass mächtige frauen für die
finnen normalität sind
fünf frauen regieren das land wie fühlt
sich das leben an
ich denke das ist schon die sind ein
bisschen jünger als ich mag das wirklich
fühlt sich an wie jemand mit dem ich
mich identifizieren kann sie sind sehr
starke frau
frauen und männer sind leicht definitiv
das ist eine gute sache aber
exzellent die repräsentieren uns sie
sind jung gebildete menschen so wie wir
beide ist es doch toll so viele frauen
im parlament zu sehen
ja es ist inspirierend für alle
jungfrauen andere frauen in
machtpositionen zu sehen die
entscheidungen für uns treffen
auf eines ist die bildungsministerin lee
andersen besonders stolz dass dieser
musterland finnland ist gut durch die
krise gekommen
flächendeckende digitalisierung eine
einheitliche lernplattform laptops für
alle haben das leben von familien
einfacher gemacht
dazu gibt es überall 24 stunden kitas
ein neues elternzeitgesetz soll die
erziehungszeit gerecht auf beide
elternteile verteilen in einem wahnsinns
tempo ist sie anders und unterwegs ohne
personenschutz immer zu fuß zur
mittagspause möchte sie mit mir in ein
deutsches café praktisch weil es nach
ministerium liegt wir reden über familie
sie haben gerade eine kleine tochter
bekommen und elternzeit
meine tochter ist im januar geboren und
ich habe meine position als ministerin
für ein halbes jahr verlassen und
elternzeit genommen
und alle haben gesagt oh nein aber als
ich zurück haben hat meine kollegin
maria osl von den grünen öffentlich
gemacht dass sie am ende des jahres ein
baby bekommen wird und auch sie wird
dann als ministerin elternzeit nehmen
ich denke das ist toll denn das ist
wirklich etwas neues es ist schön weil
es zeigt du kannst für eine längere zeit
weg sein und zurückkommen es ist nicht
das ende der welt nicht das ende seiner
karriere
vom vorreiter finnland zum schlusslicht
in sachen gleichberechtigung
kinder und karriere für frauen in
italien immer noch ein problem warum
frage ich mich hinten sie hier so
hinterher
was ist die rolle der frau nina waschen
bügeln kochen und arm schon das stimmt
doch macht sie alles machen
[Gelächter]
gibt es gleiche chancen für frauen und
männer wir haben noch einen langen weg
vor uns
es geht fast immer nur mein aussehen
mein körper nicht um meinen intellekt
ich habe mich früher nicht geschminkt da
bekam ich auf der arbeit oft gesagt dass
ich wie eine leiche aussehe und mal
lieber make up auftragen sollte
ich war fast zehn jahre lang
korrespondentin in rom mein sohn ist
hier aufgewachsen
vollzeitjob mit kind das war schon
damals eine herausforderung für mütter
in italien hat sich daran gar nichts
geändert
das möchte ich von maria pia pizol ante
wissen die 38-jährige ist autorin
aktivistin und mitglied der
sozialdemokratischen partei pd sie ist
viel unterwegs setzt sich für
chancengleichheit ein ihr sohn matthias
ist ein jahr alt und hat jetzt erst mal
mama macht jetzt nudeln mit tomatensoße
wie ist denn der alltag einer mutter in
italien
nun das leben einer mama
ich denke da gibt es verschiedene leben
es kommt darauf an ob und welchen job du
hast ob du arbeitest oder nicht
ob du großeltern in den er hasst die dir
helfen können und
kindergartenplätze gibt es zu wenige
wenige vor allem in rom vor allem in
einer stadt die viel mehr brauchen würde
also für eine frau die arbeiten will ist
es kompliziert sehr kompliziert
maria und ihr freund arbeiten beide
einen kindergartenplatz für mattia haben
sie bisher nicht typisch für italien nur
knapp 28 prozent der kinder unter drei
jahren gehen in eine betreuung die folge
über die hälfte aller frauen mit einem
oder zwei kindern bleibt zu hause oder
sie verzichten auf kinder die
geburtenrate sinkt kontinuierlich
italien hat die durchschnittlich älteste
bevölkerung in der eu
[Musik]
es gibt hier eine menge gerede über la
familia die familie alles heuchelei was
wir wirklich bräuchten sind
investitionen und kindergärten eine
politik die frauen bestärkt und fördert
so dass sie sich selbstständig machen
oder berufstätig sein können allein die
statistiken in unserem land zu frauen in
führungspositionen sind doch peinlich
italien bildet das schlusslicht in der
eu wenn es um thema gleichberechtigung
im job geht familie oder arbeit maria
ist es leid sich entscheiden zu müssen
[Musik]
ich habe als mutter viele dinge erfahren
die ich mir früher als eine überzeugte
feministin die viele kämpfe für und mit
frauen geführt hat nie hätte vorstellen
können
ich glaube die politik hat es zu lange
versäumt diese andere perspektive
einzunehmen weil sie ausschließlich von
männern dominiert wurde
mittlerweile gibt es auch in italien
frauen die politik gestalten in einem
land in dem die politik immer noch
hauptsächlich eine männerdomäne ist der
frauen auf das schmückendes beiwerk
wahrgenommen werden
mara cabana ist ministerin für
süditalien und zusammenhalt seit 2004
ist die juristin in der politik mitglied
der konservativen partei forza italia
von silvio berlusconi
karriere an der seite eines mannes der
über die grenzen italiens hinaus für
sexismus und frauenfeindlichkeit bekannt
ist
etliche showgirls verhelfe zu posten in
der politik einfach weil sie gut
aussahen auch mara cavani arbeitete
früher als model das kapitel berlusconi
will sie eigentlich hinter sich lassen
[Musik]
minister von der konstante queen italien
aus meiner zeit als korrespondent in mir
ist mir ein satz von berlusconi in
erinnerung geblieben zumindest in
unserer partei sind frauen schön und sie
stinken nicht wie in anderen parteien
was denken sie wenn sie einen solchen
satz hören
solche aussagen sind immer unangenehm
egal von wem sie stammen ich erinnere
mich nicht an diesen satz aber wenn sie
sich daran erinnern bedeutet das dass er
wohl so gesagt wurde was ich ihnen sagen
kann ist dass ich immer meine
missbilligung gegenüber
diskriminierenden oder unangenehmen
urteilen gegenüber frauen zum ausdruck
gebracht habe und bringe egal von wem
sie stammen
denn selbst sexismus erlebt in ihrer
karriere
sie aber stand's genug wie viele
unendlich viele andere frauen musste ich
viel mehr lernen und arbeiten um zu
zeigen was ich kann
in deutschland endet die ära merkel wann
werden sie in italien eine frau ist
premiere haben wäre doch zeit
ich denke italien ist bereit für eine
premierministerin und ich denke wir
bekommen eine wirklich starke botschaft
aus europa und deutschland
wenn ich an das europa von heute denke
dass von drei frauen geführt wird angela
merkel ursula von der leyen christine
lagarde
ich denke also es ist ein mächtiges
signal dass ländern wie italien hilft
die türen für frauen aufzustoßen
doch was passiert wenn ein vorbild
allein nicht reicht das erlebe ich im
kosovo
weg mit den institutionen des
patriarchats rufen sie vor einem
polizeirevier wieder seine frau ermordet
worden eine 18 jährige es sind die immer
gleichen geschichten von unterdrückung
und gewalt und die frauen im kosovo sind
es leid
[Applaus]
wir sind hier um zu sagen dass gewalt
gegen frauen nicht tolerierbar ist wir
können das nicht länger tolerieren wir
hoffen dass es nicht noch mehr fälle im
kosovo gibt jedes mädchen und jede frau
sollte frei seien glücklich mit ihrem
leben und sie sollte am leben seien
der ehemann ist tatverdächtig tage lang
solle seine frau grausam gequält haben
die polizei kennt ihn mehr als 100
straftaten begangen trotzdem war auf
freiem fuß es sind solche strukturen die
selbst die justizministerin verzweifeln
lassen betreffen sie am rande der demo
die regierung und ich als justiz
ministerin sind sehr besorgt wegen der
dominanz der patriarchalen mentalität
vor allem in den sicherheits und justiz
sich dazu
weil diese mentalität herrscht gehen die
verantwortlichen staatliche
einrichtungen einfach nicht gegen fälle
häuslicher gewalt vor die tödliche
den kosovo hat der krieg geprägt und
damit männer überall in pristina fall
mehr die statuen von gucci kämpfern auf
die ende der 90er jahre für die
unabhängigkeit von serbien gekämpft
haben
acht von ihnen wird vor dem
sondertribunal in den haag der prozess
gemacht darunter auch dem ex präsidenten
an der spitze des kosovo den jüngsten
start in europa steht jetzt eine frau
joscha osmani 39 jahre alt in den usa
ausgebildete rechtsprofessorin bei der
parlamentswahl erhielt die
liberal-konservative die meisten
direktstimmen ge frühjahr wurde sie zur
staatspräsidentin gewählt mit dem
präsident frau präsidentin sie sind seit
april offiziell im amt weiß dass die
zeiten des patriarchats im kosovo sind
vorbei
die sind nicht vorbei wieder im kosovo
noch in vielen anderen ländern auf der
welt aber es bedeutet dass unsere
gesellschaft einen wichtigen schritt
richtung emanzipation getan hat indem
sie einer frau die meisten stimmen
gegeben hat und damit ihr vertrauen
gegenüber frauen in der politik im
allgemeinen gezeigt hat
selbst haben auch schon anfeindungen im
parlament und auf social media erlebt
bedauerlicherweise ja in meinem fall
habe ich eine ganz einfache regeln
wann immer es angriffe gibt verbal oder
andere wann immer ich mich schwer tue
das hinter mir zu lassen
wann immer ich daran denke aufzugeben
dann denke ich an die kleinen mädchen zu
schauen die mich ganz genau beobachten
und die hoffen dass ich das nicht tue
denn wenn ich aufgebe heißt das auch
dass ich all die hürden und probleme
ihnen überlassen
der kosovo ist ein armes land das
durchschnittseinkommen liegt bei 300
euro nur zwölf prozent der frauen sind
erwerbstätig
wer die gesellschaft hier verstehen will
muss zum denkmal für die heldinnen des
kosovo-krieges was ist eigentlich ein
denkmal für die opfer für 20.000
vergewaltigte frauen das große trauma
und ein thema das bis heute
totgeschwiegen wird
das schweigen brechen bettina die wir
schon auf der demo getroffen haben mit
anderen jungen frauen kämpft sie gegen
tabus gerade haben sie eine app
entwickelt sex aufklärung im smartphone
zeitalter sie geben auch eine zeitung
heraus feminismus findet trainer sei
nötiger denn je
wir haben hier immer noch eine eher
patriarchalische kultur und die kann
auch die sicht von mädchen auf sich
selbst oder ihre rolle in der
gesellschaft beeinflussen
wir haben zum beispiel so eine regel die
besagt dass mädchen ihre brüder beim
essen bedienen müssen
und ja wirklich das gibt es noch in
vielen städten im kosovo
glaubt ihr seid die erste generation von
feministinnen im kosovo nein auf keinen
fall ohne diese frauen wären dementieren
es wäre nicht möglich das zu machen was
sie jetzt tun
was ist euer ziel 50 prozent von allem
auf die gleiche art gehört zu werden
dieselben möglichkeiten zu haben unsere
eigenen entscheidungen treffen zu können
und ja 50 prozent von allem
noch sind sie nicht so weit noch nie gab
es eine weibliche premierministerin im
parlament sitzen 30 prozent frauen dafür
sorgt eine immer noch umstrittene quote
ich kann ihnen sagen wie schwierig es
war die männer zu überzeugenden
praktisch jeder partei und damit hat es
ja nicht aufgehört praktisch vor jeder
neuen wahl gibt es versuche die
wahllisten zu ändern politiker die
versuchen die quote wieder abzuschaffen
das heißt dass wir als frauen egal von
welcher partei oder volksgruppe und
zusammengetan haben um die quote zu
sichern das war die richtige wahl die
richtige entscheidung
sie sich als feministin bezeichnet
absolut weil das heißt dass ich
gleichheit zwischen männern und frauen
anstrebe und das ist ein hehres ziel
zurück in finnland zurück zu lassen
gerade kommt sie aus dem regierung sitzt
die chefin der koalitionsparteien haben
sich abgestimmt frauen davon ist sie
überzeugt können es lernen gehört zu
werden
alle guten redner haben trainiert um
gute redner zu werden jeder den ich in
der politik kenne hat auch irgendwie
gelernt öffentliche auftritte zu
absolvieren und für mich war es nützlich
zu denken dass immer wenn ich irgendwo
bin ich mir ein bisschen von diesem raum
nehmen muss ich zwinge mich etwas zu
sagen
uns manchmal ist das ein desaster aber
je öfter du das gemacht hast desto
schneller vergisst du die zeiten in
denen man nicht so gut gesprochen hast
wie du das wollte
in deutschland endet nach 16 jahren die
ihrer von angela merkel glauben sie dass
das geschlecht entscheidend ist ja das
geschlecht ist entscheidend denn wenn
man sich unsere gesellschaft anschaut
sind wir immer noch weit entfernt davon
dass das geschlecht nicht entscheidend
wäre sehen sie sich selbst als vorbild
es ist schwer mich selbst als vorbild zu
sehen na ja ich kenne mich und all die
dinge in denen ich nicht so gut bin und
wissen sie ich konzentriere mich darauf
wie ich meine arbeit besser machen
könnte aber ich weiß für viele leute in
finnland und auch in anderen ländern ist
diese regierung eine art vorbild wir
sind sehr glücklich viele junge frauen
in politischer verantwortung zu sehen
und klar ich bin glücklich wenn wir
andere mit unserem beispiel inspirieren
können
auf meiner reise bin ich frauen begegnet
die ganz oben angekommen sind und die
noch immer kämpfen gegen vorurteile
dagegen dass für sie oft andere regeln
gelten als für männer frauen an der
macht noch immer keine
selbstverständlichkeit
[Musik]